hey guys it is the 12th of August today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
tuned into the Wednesday edition off
gamespot news it's pretty similar to the
other editions but completely exclusive
to wednesday after months of minor
stability patches we now know will
finally be treated to a major patch for
the ps4 as the systems 4.0 update is
currently in beta testing none of the
reports have been officially confirmed
by Sony but multiple sources have
reported that the update will add the
ability to publish 10 second video clips
to Twitter as well as the ability to
host a live gameplay broadcasts via
youtube the update will also bring in a
new communities feature which will let
you find players with similar tastes and
interests in these communities you can
chat join parties play games and post in
the watch new community feed the update
is also promising layout redesigns in
areas including live from PlayStation
and messages you can check out the full
list of patch notes on gamespot Larian
studios have announced that divinity
original spin is getting a sequel the
first divinity original sin took to
Kickstarter to secure its funding which
finished at just under 1 million bucks
and the studio have said they will be
using Kickstarter for the sequel also
the funding campaign is set to go live
on August 26 but prior to that lorien
studios are asking their fans what
rewards they want to see offered nothing
about the second game has been revealed
at this stage but they confirmed a
prototype will be playable at pax prime
and the studio were calling it their
most ambitious RPG ever which to be fair
is a phrase that gets thrown around by
deaf studios an awful lot Resident Evil
fans have something to be excited about
today as it's finally been announced
that Resident Evil 2 is going to be
remade for current console the news of
the classic PlayStation survival horror
game would be remade came by a video
from producer yoshiaki hirabayashi
hirabayashi also produced the HD
remaster of the resident
GameCube remake which came out in
January capcom released a statement
confirming that the residents able to
remake has been approved for development
although it's been indicated that the
project is in the very early stages the
company of called re-releases a key
business activity highlighting the sales
of the resident evil HD remaster were
higher than expected let me know in the
comments if Resident Evil 2 is the
remake you were excited for or if
there's another game you'd like to see
modernize heja games but we've got news
on leaked fallout 4 gameplay and game a
drug test that is all the good stuff
from today let me know down in the
comments what mattered to you and I will
catch you same time tumor